and speak to cancer survivor and former
good morning america host joan london
and steve alperin the chief executive of
vice platform survivor
net hello to you both thank you very
much indeed for being with us
i want to come on to the potential good
news in
a moment but we've had figures out here
in the uk from cancer research uk
today that some 40 000 fewer people
started cancer treatment in 2020.
cancer hasn't gone away joan by any
stretch has it so how concerning is it
that those diagnoses are being missed
and treatment delayed
you know sarah i was just interviewing a
doctor yesterday who said to me that
they expect this
huge onslaught of
late diagnoses because people are so
reluctant to go into
a medical facility and we know how
important early diagnosis is in breast
cancer
like i had or certainly in skin cancer
in you know if you're not getting your
colonoscopy and your annual skin check
and your annual gynecological checkup
and your mammogram
um you could be putting yourself in
great danger so it's important that
everyone realizes that
these medical centers have been made
safe for us now and you need to go and
have those checkups
yeah and steve um getting a diagnosis at
any time
is incredibly distressing but
particularly
now that the fear is even more
exaggerated what do
users of your platform say and what
advice are you able to give them
thanks for so much for having us on
sarah there are
millions of people who come to us who
are even more afraid
and more anxious about what they might
find
and so what we try to do is take the
information and and decrease that
anxiety just a little bit
um it is safe to go get a mammogram
there are many many tens of thousands of
people every day in each city
going to have these procedures so the
number one thing is go get
checked you don't want to wait if
something's wrong please
go um the people who are doing this
stuff now want to be safe
and it can be done very safely that's
the number one message for prevention
which is still the most powerful tool we
have against cancer
prevention and early screening yeah
really important
messages there joan one of the positives
that has come out of this pandemic
though
is the power of science and when the
global community
comes together we have seen huge
acceleration in scientific breakthroughs
could we see that benefiting the world
of cancer and helping cancer patients
well amazingly a lot of the research
that's been done and
the breakthroughs that we've seen in the
treatment of covid are actually turning
out to be very helpful
in the treatment for cancer but you know
just since my diagnosis which was only
about six years ago
there have been so many advancements
there was no treatment at all for the
kind of
cancer no targeted treatment for triple
negative cancer which i had
and now there are um immunotherapy i
mean that has been the
game changer and it used to be that
you know if a woman had metastatic
breast cancer that was really
a death sentence and we now are learning
um
how to and the goal of course is to make
it a
manageable chronic illness and so
it's really important all the millions
of dollars that have gone
into breast cancer research but i want
to just talk about some of the basics
if you're do yourself exams know your
own
normal so that if anything seems awry
you get that checked right away
you need to be a self-advocate today
whether it's trying to get a
covert vaccination or whether it's
trying to get a second opinion and when
you're facing a life-threatening
disease such as cancer don't be
reluctant to get a second opinion
take somebody with you in for those
first early appointments where
big decisions are made about treatment
women you need to understand what your
breast density
is i didn't know anything about this i
got a clean
3d mammogram the day of my diagnosis and
then i had an ultrasound and found out i
had stage 2
triple negative breast cancer dense
tissue shows up white on a mammogram and
so does cancer
it's very easy to miss a cancer
diagnosis
so if you don't know what your breast
density is and you get mammograms
you call up that radiation clinic that
you went to and ask
if you have very dense tissue because
it's really important to know
you need to know your family history
that's so important
and we still live in a time when a lot
of parents never
really talked about it if they had
cancer they might have been very secret
about it
and you need to kind of get through that
but at the same time
if you never had any family history like
me and you thought well it's not going
to happen to me
only less than 15 percent of women
diagnosed with breast cancer
ever had a family history yeah lots of
questions
to be asked lots of research to be done
and of course
uh checking uh yourself as well steve
we've talked a lot about the mrna
technology
over recent months something many of us
would not have heard of before but is
now
playing a huge part in our lives in the
role out of the fisa vaccine
for example that technology
is there a chance that that could be
used in the fight against cancers
in the future that company with
two i believe turkish emigrates to
germany was originally a cancer company
so i think to put in perspective number
one on world cancer day you have to
acknowledge
the human toll is still extraordinary
and extreme however
we are living through a world historical
moment
in cancer and in medicine in the last
eight years the number of new methods of
of treating disease has doubled before
that for the 100 year history of met
of modern science there might have been
10 or 15 methods in the last 10 years
including
mrna we have doubled that
so if you think about the moment of
these these pathways to attack disease
there is a true industrial revolution
that's not my term there
the people reading it have come with
that term in biotech
and so i think the opportunity for
humanity if you look at 15 of the top
20 pharma companies globally including
some extraordinary uk companies
are betting their financial future i
know somebody who last friday was on a
call
for investors organized by number 10
which the prime minister attended
and it was all about how in the uk can
we take
the extraordinary life science cluster
of academics
and cluster of companies and accelerate
it so
that this moment can be transformed i'll
leave you with one way to look at it
in cancer specifically um in in the u.s
with a president called richard nixon he
declared war on cancer 50 years ago
something like a trillion dollars of
money and 200 medicines mostly
chemotherapies
in the last seven or eight years there
have been 50 to 60 new medicines so the
curve
is like that but it's not good enough
right now what's happening
in in the great universities in the
world in the great pharma companies
they're trying to figure out the next
answers why doesn't immunotherapy work
for some people how can we use mrna
how can we speed up drug development
with ai and so the moment
is extraordinary you see it in in the
public health data in the uk
there's a there's a 20-year period with
a 15 decline in death
in the u.s for the first time in history
treatment
is making a difference for cancer
mortality rather than prevention and so
they
the short form is it's an incredible
positive moment yeah some really
potentially positive news
on the horizon joan i just want to get
your final thoughts
um i know you spend a lot of time
advising and guiding
women as they get a cancer diagnosis
from your own personal experience and to
get a diagnosis now
at a point when fears are exacerbated
fears about
access to treatment fears about catching
covid when your immune system
is compromised but when those support
networks that we would normally rely on
that access to friends and family
are taken away from us what
what can women do and how do you advise
them to get through
the most difficult times well i do think
a support network is really
important especially you know right in
the beginning you put together your
your group of doctors because it's just
not one doctor that treats you
when you're battling cancer and this is
not the time to say i'm type a woman and
i could do this by myself
which i was inclined i was very happy
though that my family said oh no we're
going to be here to support you
but it's also important to make sure
you're getting the right information
and we're living in a time of
just unimaginable disinformation and
misinformation
which can be so dangerous when it comes
to our health that's the reason why i
you know was happy when survivor.net
called me um
steve is the founder of it and because i
knew it was a reliable
platform that was well researched that
you know was caught in constant contact
with doctors
so be very careful where you get your
information at the same time
ask a lot of questions because
everything you just heard from
steve so many new treatments are coming
down the pike when i was diagnosed there
was
a brand new treatment available and i
chose to take it and i think that's
you know one of the reasons why i did so
well so
yeah so it's really been you know we're
not just doing standard of care anymore
they really are doing personalized care
for each person
so that's really a good thing about the
change in
cancer care recently